moi je vous ai dit avec Christophe sur
ma propre sur la première descends plus
grand vraiment c'est la première fois de
toute ma carrière ça fait 25 ans je fais
de la télé en 25 ans c'est la première
fois que je suis partie de l'émission à
la fin de l'émission Sans le sans saluer
mon co-animateur et pourtant à TF1
j'étais madame duo je faisais tous les
duos avec tous les animateurs de la
chaîne quasiment et je suis parti en
claquant la porte et c'est la première
fois et je ne fais jamais ça j'ai pas de
mouvement d'humeur moi donc vraiment et
[Musique]
Étienne moujat à l'époque a appelé
Christophe en lui disant je serais toi
j'appellerai Valérie quand même parce
que ça serait bien que vous parliez que
voilà et Christophe et c'est pour ça que
je dis une fois que une fois qu'on dit
les choses tout s'est bien passé m'a
envoyé un petit mot son nom quand même
non mais en me disant je n'ai pas eu
conscience de ce que j'avais fait à quel
point j'avais été dit dur et difficile
je te prie de m'en excuser un homme qui
s'excuse je trouve que c'est absolument
admirable et donc après c'est de
l'excuser d'avoir été dur un homme qui
s'excuse admirable
et à partir de là on a passé une année
sans problème
j'ai eu un problème avec Thierry
Ardisson ça avait été très violent
j'allais pour la promo d'un de mes
livres dans tout le monde en parle
c'était 2013 je me souviens et non 2003
tout le monde en parle et en fait il me
dit qu'on a un problème technique et un
problème de son il faut que je répète le
pitch de mon livre et donc je le répète
trois fois et il me dit dans
l'oreillette Catherine barman me dit
qu'on a un problème technique donc il
faut que vous répétiez s'il vous plaît
le pitch de votre livre donc je le
répète je venais d'accoucher cinq jours
avant j'étais hyper fébrile à l'époque
c'est une grosse émission pour un auteur
et donc ben en fait il a gardé trois
fois au montage expérimente et il m'a
fait passer pour une gourde et j'avais
trouvé ça hyper violent hyper humiliant
[Musique]
je me raconte l'histoire je suis dans ma
loge cool
s'entendait bien avec Thierry Ardisson
vraiment bien tu vois et à l'époque on
était en face Laurent Ruquier moi
Laurent Laurent faisait l'accès sont
face et on a eu des petites déclarations
après suite trucs et moi et maintenant
et je le dis et si vous voulez je le dis
à chaque fois Laurent et moi je pense
que c'est un de mes animateurs vraiment
préféré Laurent on en a discuté ici et
c'est le seul mec Laurent Ruquier quand
il était un peu tendu entre nous deux il
a dit mais on va prendre un café tous
les deux et puis comme ça on se dit tout
et c'est vrai que Laurent est depuis on
est devenu vraiment je l'adore et je
suis très très pote avec enfin je j'aime
beaucoup en tout cas pas pote on s'en va
c'est pas beau mais je l'aime beaucoup
voilà il est adorable avec tout le monde
vraiment ouais et c'est un super mec
Laurent vraiment c'est un super mec et
je suis dans ma loge et j'ai le retour
et je suis dans ma loge avec mon bras
droit j'ai deux bras droits j'en ai
plusieurs mais voilà et Loïc est à côté
de moi et on regarde et il lui disent
ouais cyril a dit on avait dit j'ai dit
je veux pas être sur le même plateau que
Laurent Laurent il y avait Laurent qui
est invité je dis quand Laurent s'en va
je viens et là il y a Ardisson je
l'entends il sait pas que j'ai le retour
il dit bah il va fermer sa gueule et il
va venir ici et il va se mettre à côté
de requin j'adore donc là je vois ça je
suis dans ma loge donc Thierry de venir
me voir normalement
donc je lui dis donc ils disent il veut
pas dire il veut pas mon il veut pas
descendre donc il faut monter le doigt
donc qui monte me voir voilà je dis à
mon assistant mon bras droit de sortir
j'ai fermé la loge on a une petite
discussion et
finalement ça s'est très bien passé
rabibouché le sujet voilà
non non parce que j'ai pas aimé et voilà
c'est toujours moi je préfère moi je
préfère un mec devant moi qui dit non
mais tu nous fais chier il serait monté
il m'aurait dit Cyril tu me fais chier
tu vas faire l'émission avec Laurence
mais voilà après c'est vrai que si vous
alors vraiment si on devait vous trouvez
vraiment on le met tous des pincettes
ici je crois tout le monde un petit
défaut mais vraiment comme ça en
filigran voilà je dirais sanguin mais
sanguin en deux mots
puisque après
10 minutes après c'est je t'aime bébé
perfectionniste sur une perfectionniste
moi je me suis engueulé violemment avec
Benjamin Castaldi aussi je sais mais
c'était juste avant vous et il s'est
couché au téléphone donc ça a été voir
raconte-nous une vraie histoire
raconte-nous une vraie histoire une
vraie là non mais là c'est une vraie
histoire c'est le temps était monté et
une engueule à monumentale Pascal Praud
qui est un ami lors d'une émission On
refait le match mais monumental mais moi
aussi c'est un ami mais pendant une
pause publicitaire mais des insultes
non refait le match avec Eugène
Saccomano presque venu aux mains à tel
point que j'avais disjoncté totalement
j'avais vrillé
non parce que je brille pas je me
contrôle j'entendais je me contrôle et
là moi je pense que tu vis comme tes
amis
mes amis
on les connaît à tel point ce ne sont
pas mes amis et donc j'avais vrillé
complètement j'avais insulté un
entraîneur lors de l'émission ce qui m'a
valu un procès j'avais complètement pété
les plombs une fois ça m'est très
rarement arrivé et depuis je ne sors
plus de mes gond voilà Joey Starr non là
c'est lui c'est lui c'est lui en fait
calme tu dis pas de bêtises toi tu t'es
embrouillé avec qui moi j'ai une
embrouille avec Guy luxe
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon là
pour les plus jeunes c'est qui
aujourd'hui c'est c'est vraiment le
temps
c'est un boss des variété franchement
j'étais hyper
impressionné
[Rires]
j'avais 25 ans je l'attendais pour
passer un entretien il me fait attendre
1h30 qui dit luxe ouais il arrive mais
vraiment méprisant il me dit bah c'est
bien vous m'avez attendu vous êtes
patiente et alors faut vous dire que
j'étais à 25 ans j'étais habillé encore
moins moderne que maintenant donc il me
fait toute façon avec le look que vous
avez vous devez pas être très occupé
voilà donc
je ne suis absolument personne
je suis personne à l'époque et Patrick
Sébastien a besoin d'un auteur pour
écrire un gars qui distribue des
calendrier de Bonne Année bon j'écris
quelques sketchs on a pour quatre ou
cinq minutes c'était 1000 francs la
minute 1000 francs million si en France
et Guy Lux percevait en amont les droits
d'auteur donc moi j'attendais juste
qu'il me rembourse l'argent qu'il avait
touché qui me paye c'est à l'époque ce
secrétaire je la salue je l'embrasse
c'est Marie Schneider si tu nous
regardes et le donc
j'attends
j'attends un mois deux mois c'est
possible
il va peut-être vous donner peut-être
que 3000 elle me dit au téléphone je
l'ai au téléphone moi je crève la dalle
je ne suis absolument rien je me fais
une télé de ma vie et puis ça passe ça
passe et là elle dit Oh écoute écoutez
Jean-Marie là il est là Monsieur luxe
elle me dit je vais lui demander
monsieur
et attends remonter fun elle me dit
Monsieur luxe préférerait donner que
1000 et moi j'ai dit comme on était
passé de 6000 j'ai dit qu'il me les
donne maintenant parce que dans 2 mois
c'est moi qui vais lui devoir de
l'argent comme comme c'est parti et
ensuite et un coup je fais la je fais la
classe devient la star de la classe il
fait une spéciale de la classe avec Jean
Lefebvre tout ça machin et il me dit
qu'on est dans mon salaire jimmo salaire
c'est quoi elle me dit c'est 1000 et moi
j'ai demandé à mon frère qui était à
l'époque qui travaillait pour moi je dis
dis-lui que Monsieur Bigard préférée 20
[Applaudissements]